hey I'm Kennedy for reason TV I got kids
during the holidays I like to sit down
with my girls and watch some
family-friendly freedom focused films
about Christmas cheer and when I'm
chugging my hundred proof gluten free
eggnog I want to make sure my girls are
mainlining Liberty so with the help of
recent film critic and my good friend
Kurt Loder we put together a list of
classic holiday movies to avoid and to
imbibe all to help you enjoy a
responsible libertarian Christmas
first up the cinematic lumps of coal a
Charlie Brown Christmas the titular
blockhead is offended by the
commercialization of Christmas which is
a neat trick to pull off during a
Christmas special sponsored by Dolly
Madison snack cakes I don't care poor
little Charlie Brown is clearly an enemy
of capitalism who probably grows up to
join occupy hell everything I touch gets
ruined a Christmas memory propagates the
unlimited idea but getting blind drunk
during the holidays is somehow wrong are
you out of your mind
Love Actually propagates the unliberated
idea that getting blind drunk and
watching porn during the holidays is
somehow wrong rubbish white Christmas to
showbiz sisters played by Vera Ellen and
George Clooney's aunt rosemary destroy
an expensive rug that is the private
property of their landlord instead of
making ethically necessary restitution
they run out on this obligation this is
offensive and not just to libertarians
Miracle on 34th Street after Kris
Kringle is dispatched to the nervous
Hospital for insisting that he's really
Santa Claus
the post office saves the day nuff said
you're making the mistake
FedEx would have sprung him overnight
now to be fair there was some debate
about this movie in the reason office
with Mike Riggs hooked to point out it's
one of his favorite Pro libertarian
Christmas movies because it exposes
government corruption and showcases the
horrors of involuntary commitment now
here are the good libertarian Christmas
movies we need these right my favorite
is Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer Oh
Rudolph Rudolph's distinguishing
characteristic is universally seen as a
deformity and he's outcast from the
reindeer games and the herd yet through
self-examination and Riaan
mention he turns his perceived
impairment into an asset and becomes the
most popular reindeer of all time in the
process he saves his gal and his parents
and befriends precious-metal loving
prospector Yukon kornelius I'd love to
get my life-sustaining supplies cornmeal
and gunpowder and a ham hocks and guitar
strings then there's the brief moment in
the sentimental holiday Standard It's a
Wonderful Life
when bankster George Bailey travels to
Pottersville the place his hometown of
Bedford Falls would have become if he'd
never been born now we only see
Pottersville for a few moments but it
looks to be a city comprised solely of
four houses and gin mills which is
pretty awesome
Hey ha and Merry Christmas my other
holiday favorite which is not itself a
Christmas movie but has become one over
the years by default is the sound of
music which is endlessly loveable how
could you not adorable plucky
anti-authoritarian none who's a thorn in
the side of the church and the loins of
the tyrannical naval captain whom she
wins over despite making later hosing
out of green drapes that she also takes
down the entire Nazi regime Natchez
gravy really now which other movies
deserve to make it on our list anti
libertarian holiday movies have no place
in a freedom friendly family room always
looking out for you for recent TV I'm
Kennedy
you